-At the end of last year,
their 2015 song "Alien Blues"
blew up on TikTok,
streaming over one million
times a day,
and now, they're over
150 million streams to date.
Making their late night debut,
please welcome to the show
Vundabar!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Was it the best
you ever had? ♪
♪ Was it the worst?
You'd never know ♪
♪ I try to tell you
what I think ♪
♪ And play it off
like it's a joke ♪
♪ Oh, no, more surprises,
guess it's like this ♪
♪ I'd do anything for you,
Mrs. Highness ♪
♪ Na na na na na na na ♪
♪ Na na na na na na ♪
♪ Oh oh oh oh oh oh! ♪
♪ Na na na na na na na na ♪
♪ Na na na na na na ♪
♪ Na na na na na na na ♪
♪ Oh oh oh oh oh oh! ♪
♪♪
♪ The sun is fun,
the land is dandy ♪
♪ I only talk to dogs because
they don't understand me ♪
♪ My teeth are yellow,
hello, world ♪
♪ Would you like me
a little better ♪
♪ If they were white
like yours? ♪
♪ I need to purge my urges,
shame, shame, shame ♪
♪ I need an alibi to justify,
somebody to blame ♪
♪ It's a halibut, party bitch ♪
♪ Give it a name and say,
hey, hey ♪
♪ Na na na na na na na ♪
♪ Na na na na na na ♪
♪ Oh oh oh oh oh oh! ♪
♪ Na na na na na na na ♪
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Vundabar, everybody!